despite the federal government under
Trump and Jeff Sessions moving more and
more and more against marijuana yet
another state is moving forward towards
decriminalization and legalization this
time it's Virginia the Senate in
Virginia voted anonymously 42 zero to
legalize medical marijuana extracts in
the state this is bill SB 726 and it
would allow doctors in Virginia to
recommend cannabidiol oil or THC oil for
treating a variety of conditions and
diseases House already passed its
version of the bill governor expected to
sign it CBD and THC a have been shown
effective at dealing with patients
suffering from epilepsy people who need
help managing pain and a number of other
conditions and Virginia is interesting
because they're also being hit very hard
by the opioid crisis and we have studies
from other states that show us not at
all surprisingly that when you legalized
or decriminalized medical and/or
recreational marijuana opioid overdoses
decrease and you know there are people
rightly pointing out David this is so
minor not only is it medical and not
recreational it's just extracts CBD and
THC a it's not even the medical smoking
of the marijuana plant you're right but
the momentum is clear right and my view
on this Pat is when you've got the
federal government going so far so
aggressively in the opposite direction
any step forward even just this from
Virginia is something that we should be
glad about an applaud yeah and to get
that unanimous vote it required 21
Republicans which you have seen even ten
years ago and I think the GOP is giving
up on this issue it's the next social
issue that they're gonna lose maybe at
the state level I mean federally
sessions are still pushing hard but
increasingly at the state level you see
it not a priority for Republicans and
you know we need to go as full
legalization and most importantly the
rescheduling of marijuana at the federal
level we've got to get it out of
schedule one right scheduled one is
supposed to be reserved for the most
dangerous and addicting substances with
no medical benefits cannabis clearly
does not fit into that category yet it
remains a Schedule one at the federal
level small victory but the small
victories are adding up and that's a
very very good good thing and I know
it's just extracts her medical uses a
non psychoactive non psychoactive but
it's better than nothing and eventually
they will come around we have a
discussion forum on reddit at david
pakman.com forward slash reddit check it
out discuss politics with other david
pakman show viewers and listeners we'll
take a quick break and be back with a
lot more